el rectángulo de abajo tiene una área de
12 x 46 x cúbica más 15 x cuadrada
metros cuadrados y aquí de hecho podemos
ver cómo es que está distribuido el
rectángulo verdad tenemos una zona verde
que tiene área 12 x cuarta tenemos una
zona morada que tiene área 6x cúbica y
una zona azul que tiene área 15 x
cuadrada muy bien ok
después nos dice el largo del rectángulo
en metros y de hecho aquí podemos ver el
largo verdad esta sería ésta esta
longitud sería el largo del rectángulo
es igual al máximo común factor mono
mial de 2 x cuarta 6x cúbica y 15 x
cuadrada nos preguntan cuánto miden el
largo y el ancho del rectángulo así que
como siempre trata de bueno de
resolverlo por tu cuenta hace una pausa
y luego verificamos todos juntos
muy bien aquí lo importante es ver que
el digamos la longitud que tiene el
largo por la longitud del ancho verdad
nos da exactamente el área de nuestro
rectángulo y si el largo es el máximo
común factor mono mial entonces al
factorizar lo de esta suma verdad que es
el área total nos quedará exactamente la
longitud del ancho del rectángulo así
que veamos qué es lo que podemos hacer
primero bueno primero consideremos
nuestros coeficientes muy bien voy a
hacerlo un poquito más pequeño tenemos
12 6 y 15 esos son nuestros coeficientes
así que vamos a primero a factorizar los
digamos en factores primos verdad para
poder encontrar el máximo común factor
mono mial así que tendremos el 12 verdad
este 12 lo podemos ver como 2 por 6 y 6
es dos por tres muy bien ahora tomemos
el 6 que lo podemos ver simplemente como
y el 15 que lo podemos ver como 3 por 5
muy bien entonces si nos preguntamos
cuál es el máximo común
divisor de estos tres números verdad
entonces primero tenemos que ver que el
3 es un divisor común de estos tres y es
el único verdad porque por ejemplo el 2
divide a 12 también divide a 6 pero no
divide a 15 por otro lado el 5 se divide
a 15 perón y divide a 6 ni tampoco
divide a 12 así que podemos ver que 3 es
el único factor común que tienen estos
tres números y por lo tanto será el
máximo común divisor verdad o también
podríamos haberlo visto así tenemos el
12 y podemos ver que todo se puede ser 1
por 2 de verdad también puede ser 2 por
6 o puede ser 3 por 4 verdad por otro
lado tenemos el 6 que es 1 por 6 o
también es 2 por 3 y finalmente el 15 lo
podemos ver como 1 por 15 o 3 por 5
verdad entonces de todos estos divisores
que tienen tanto el 12 el 6 y el 15
podemos ver que él
más grande que está en común con los
tres es el 3 verdad así que este es el
más grande y que está presente en todos
así que nuestro máximo como un factor
mono mial tendrá como como coeficiente
al número 3 verdad ahora vamos a
fijarnos en las potencias de x aquí
tenemos x 4x cúbica y x cuadrada así que
si nos fijamos cuál sería el digamos el
factor mono mial más grande que podemos
obtener de estos tres verdad que es x 4a
x cúbica y x cuadrada pues simplemente
será x cuadrada verdad muy bien así que
este es el máximo como un factor mono
mial de 2 x 4 6 x cúbica y 15 x cuadrada
vamos a ponerlo acá esto será entonces
el largo de nuestro rectángulo verdad
será 3 x
cuadrada ahora la idea es que tenemos
que factorizar 3x cuadrada de esta suma
para obtener el ancho verdad así que nos
preguntamos por cuánto hay que
multiplicar a 3x cuadrada para que nos
dé 12 x 4a entonces 3 por 4 nos da 12 y
x cuadrada por x cuadrada nos da x 4a
ahí tenemos este este mono mío verdad 4
x cuadrada ahora veamos qué es lo que
ocurre con la parte morada muy bien
hagamos la parte morada y entonces vemos
que 3 por 2 nos da 6 y x cuadrada por x
nos da x cúbica y finalmente 3 por 5 nos
dará 15 y x cuadrada por 1 simplemente
nos da x cuadrada verdad entonces lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar
estos 3 y ya tenemos la expresión para
el ancho verdad simplemente lo hemos
factor izado así que ya podemos dar la
respuesta
a quienes el largo del largo de hecho es
3x cuadrada metros y el ancho será 4x
cuadrada más 2 x más 5 metros verdad
entonces de hecho lo que hemos lo que
hemos hecho hasta ahora es lo siguiente
tenemos 3x cuadradas que multiplica a 4x
cuadrada más 2 x más cinco verdad
tenemos el largo por el ancho y eso nos
debe dar el área verdad esto debe ser
exactamente igual a 12 x cuarta más 6 x
cúbica más 15 x cuadrada así que ya
tenemos quien es el largo el ancho y
vemos en efecto que el producto nos da
el área total del rectángulo